well I've thought long and hard about it
done a lot of soul-searching and
considered all the options and I finally
decided are you kidding
of course I want to keep racing are you
kidding of course I want to keep racing
the thing is if I'm going to be faster
than storm I need to train like them
look every mile of this trip was to get
me faster than Jackson storm faster
I started off getting nowhere for a week
on a simulator I lose a whole day with
you on fireball Beach and then I waste
tonight in the crosshairs a miss fritter
I'm stuck in the same speed I was a
month ago I can't get any faster because
I'm too busy taking care of my trainer
what no all ideas get my tires dirty
real racing I'm not driving on that
thing when I've got the sand and the
whole earth I don't need a trainer out
here crews well life's a beach and then
you drive well life's a beach and then
you drive this is my last chance cruise
last final finito if I lose I never get
to do this again if you were a racer you
know what I'm talking about but you're
not so you don't hear your audio as you
as you walk off so I was just looking
for some x-rays instead now so that's
your response
[Laughter]
may I have my tires back so I can go on
the simulator please Lana didn't name
them okay lefty righty Becky Becky jr.
are you satisfied this make you mad yes
it does not me man are you mad
you're going with me with that thing
yeah you still need my help - you're
brittle like a fossil I don't need a
trainer out here Cruz whoa oh boy how
was your nap mr. Macqueen Oh
refreshing actually
what's that burnt rubber smell
oh hey you've been driving on tires a
long time have you ever stopped to get
to know them you've been driving on
tires a long time have you ever stopped
to get to know them you guys gotta work
through this stuff so when your big
chance comes along you can take it and
when they started their engines that
that's when I knew I'll never be a racer
you can look in his eyes and see these
nervous today's your day mr. McQueen I
can feel it
today's your day mr. McQueen I can feel
it okay I'm sorry mr. McQueen I I didn't
mean to you know available okay got it
Wow thank you mr. McQueen you have no
idea what a pleasure it is for me to
finally meet you
yeah yeah come on come on let's get a
picture you know what get a ton of
pictures because champ here has been a
role model of mine for years now and I
mean a lot of years right I love this
guy I think I touched a nerve you know
what I just can't believe I get to race
V Lightning McQueen in his farewell
season hey champ
where'd all your friends go hey champ
where'd all your friends go
hey McQueen you alright hey listen don't
worry about it pal you had a good run
enjoy your retirement
can I play it like this like I come up
and I go well you that is a nice
costumes it's so nice to meet my number
one family he says no no whoa can I do
that oh oh hey check him you're like one
of those things yeah I just like I like
playing like I don't even see him until
he said something yeah Oh your bully at
this point yeah and you like put your
arm around the top of your dinner the
products of course have your cat arms
give them you know just kind of like
imagine you're you say that line and you
just wait and you give it a nice smile
and then for the next line hey put me
down for a few go ahead and projection
like you're walking I'm walking away
yeah sure we got a couple of broken now
I'm gonna call you mother britches and
you lemonade who why look here boys we
got us a couple of rookies now I'm gonna
call you money britches and you lemonade
Oh
I will fix that all right your license
plate gonna look real nice in my
collection I'm about to commit a moving
violation
remember obey appropriate street signs
you about to feel the wrath of the lower
bill bill counter Unified School
District it's a pleasure to be here
chicken actually I prefer the term
statistical analyst more changes ahead
check every week we've seen veteran
racers either retire like Cal weathers
tonight or fired to make room for these
younger faster racers and it's not over
yet
it's no mystery if you study the data
mr. hicks-jackson storm is part of the
next generation of high-tech racers
unlike the veterans of yesterday oh
right
storm achieves his top speeds by
exploiting the number
I refer of course to the racing data
tire pressure downforce weight
distribution aerodynamics and NextGen's
like storm are taking advantage the
racing world is changing well if I am
certain of anything chick it's that this
season is about to get even more
interesting one reason storm in the next
gens are more efficient their ability to
hold the optimum racing line every
single lap 2% lower drag coefficient 5%
increased downforce 1.2 percent higher
top speed 1:22 1:22 yeah that's it 196
196 waiting for the Hamilton here a
little bigger call it Hamilton here ok
great
Hamilton here for the next 197 197 197
grit they are here to steal our secret
that was my mood
that was my mood come on you tell that
story overnight yep that'll do yep I
don't know I'm gonna push you just get
angry yell at me what are you doing here
lean in to the mic as if you're going if
you're putting your glasses down yeah
and send not for long not for long
yeah yeah we're not for long did we
mention slow that's it well done that's
great it's great like that was wow what
a finish even the crowd seems stunned I
don't remember the last time a racer
came out of the blue to win it it's one
thing to start fast but we haven't seen
anyone cross the line with that kind of
speed and power since a young Lightning
McQueen first arrived on the scene
hello racing fans welcome to the Los
Angeles 500 final race of the Piston Cup
season it's been a year of surprises and
today promises to be no different as the
teams get ready in the pits we get ready
to bring you the action here trackside
you're watching this right you're
watching this right all storm that's a
pretty lap right there all great speed
buddy we are smoking these guys all what
a great job you are the man nobody's
beating us today bring it on home
partner bring it on home look behind you
look behind you good come back down good
come back out well then race for me will
then race for me as you know we have a
long history of great racers set for Cal
still that old timer a thing or two
don't let him pass you offer still
stands just say the word you can be my
number one car at team Dinoco good
comeback cow
good comeback cow hey lightning good
race today hey lightning good race today
uh-huh you got some what hey lighten
your eyes today man
you
you
you
it is all that's real with everybody
else to everybody else we made lots of
workshops let them let that make that
like oh yeah it's on dates before they
hurt so we're back on these guys they're
already in business mode
this company on the doorway yeah so
we're looking in the doorway he still
hasn't like he's sitting listening to
the promoter it still hasn't decided to
go out and say I'm giving you a young
contributor life
[Music]
you
you
oh he repeat imma call he cookie
government all these ridges here
actually scooted the back come on so
didn't interfere it with that fine
rounded the headlight John wanted
something sleek along the long edge and
so my thought is this is this is a strip
of LED lights right here yeah the ends
and terms of your piece of chrome oh hey
whoa you've been driving on tires a long
time if you ever stopped again - no
sorry what hires your individual you
should give each your name name them
no I will be doing that my name's Maria
horizontal Nando and Debby Richardson
what long story
this one talking to flow is know about
those today what is it a green flag is
out see the flat
what do I do oh no come
oh this is the final nail because now
all of his friends you know Cal retired
so he saw the writing on the wall and
then these two just got replaced last
minute last minute and he didn't even
know this was happening
his line McQueen does not react to it
here I think he still kind like he's so
far behind the curb right now trying to
react to anything
you